Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Sözcükler sihirdir.
Yoktan var eder, var olanı yok eder.
Düşündürür, güldürür.
Kederlendirir, keyiflendirir.
Merak ettirir, keşfettirir.
Eğitir, öğretir.
Öfkelendirir, isyan ettirir,
hatta savaş ettirir.
Mest eder, zengin eder.
En önemlisi de aşık eder, aşık.
Sözcükler büyük bir güçtür.
Sözcüklere hakim olan dünyaya hakim olur.
Ahlaklı olanın elinde sözcükler, adeta bir
büyüdür, sihirdir, tılsımdır, efsundur.
Dünyayı güzelleştiren, iyiyi, doğruyu,
güzeli, gerçeği çoğaltıp yayan.
Ahlaksız olanın elinde ise maalesef
sözcükler adeta bir kara büyüdür.
Dünyayı karartan, yalanı çoğaltan
ve kötü olanı güçlü kılan.
Şimdi düşünelim, sözcüklerin
gücü nereden geliyor?
Sözcüklerin gücü aslında
düşüncelere hükmetmesinde gizlidir.
Sözcükler, düşünceleri şekillendirir;
o düşünceler, duyguları tetikler.
O duygular, davranışlara yansır;
o davranışlar da sonuçları belirler.
Sözcüklerin gücü buradan gelir.
Şimdi size bir fizik
profesörünü takdim edeceğim.
Kuantum alanında uzman biri,
özellikle moleküler fizik konusunda
uzun yıllara dayanan araştırmaları olan
değerli bir bilim insanı.
Ama öncesinde bu fizik profesörünü
zihninizde canlandırmanızı rica ediyorum.
Soralım, bu fizik profesörünün
gözlükleri var mı?
Var diyenleri bir görebilir miyim?
Zihninizde canlandırdınız, güzel.
Peki, bu fizik profesörünün sakalı var mı?
Var diyenleri bir görebilir miyim?
Güzel.
Peki, ruj sürmüş mü?
''Ruj mu?'' diyeniniz epey çok.
Ne oldu?
Ben kadın ya da erkek
olduğundan bahsetmedim ki.
Bilim kadını, bilim adamı demedim ki.
Bilim insanı dedim.
Kuantum dedim, moleküler fizik dedim.
Uzun yıllara dayanan
araştırmaları var dedim.
Ve nedense salonun çok büyük
bir bölümü bir erkek canlandırdı.
Bir erkek fizik profesörü
canlandırdı zihninde.
İşte sözcüklerin yönlendirici gücü.
Şimdi, artık oyunun kurallarını
biliyoruz, minik bir oyun daha yapalım.
Size 20 sözcük söyleyeceğim. Hepsi o.
Bu 20 sözcüğe odaklanmanızı
ve dikkat etmenizi isteyeceğim.
Bunun için de bir ricam var.
Lütfen gözlerimizi kapatalım.
Güzel.
Hazırız.
Bıçak.
Kan.
Vahşet.
Cehennem.
Ceza.
İntikam.
Deprem.
Öfke.
Hastalık.
İhanet.
Baskı.
Kasvet.
Stres.
İşkence.
Zehir.
Tecavüz.
Terör.
Yangın.
Hapis.
Ölüm.
Gözlerinizi açabilirsiniz.
Ne oldu?
Sadece 20 sözcük söyledim.
Ama iki binden fazla kişinin bulunduğu
bu salona adeta bir kasvet çöktü,
bir sessizlik hakim oldu.
Düşünceleriniz ne oldu?
Zihninizde belki birbirinden
korkunç sahneler geçti.
Duygularınız ne oldu?
Sıkıldınız, ürperdiniz.
Davranışlarınız ne oldu?
Bir de sahneden görün yüz ifadelerinizi.
Yüzler asıldı, gerginlik oldu.
İşte sözcüklerin gücü.
Gelin şimdi bu kasvetli havayı,
güzel bir aşk hikâyesiyle dağıtalım.
Antik çağda, Pygmalion adında
bir heykeltıraş, Kıbrıslı bir heykeltıraş.
Şöyle der: ''Ben dünyanın
en güzel kadın heykelini yapacağım.
O kadar güzel olacak ki
Afrodit'ten bile daha güzel olacak.''
Gerçekten de Pygmalion söylediğini yapar,
dünyanın en güzel kadın heykelini yapar.
Ve kadın o kadar güzel olur ki
Pygmalion bu heykele aşık olur.
Ve her gün bu heykele aşk
şiirleri yazar, aşk şarkıları söyler;
aşkını güçlü, etkili sözlerle ifade eder.
Ve bir gün bu heykel canlanır.
Gerçek bir kadına dönüşür.
Yani kalpten gelen pozitif, güçlü sözler
bir taşa bile can verebilir.
Bu elbette işin hikâye boyutu,
bir de gerçek kısmı var.
1968 yılında Profesör Rosenthal,
Amerika'da, Kaliforniya'da,
ilkokul öğrencileri ile bir deney yapar.
Beş üstün zekâlı, özel, öğrenme
kapasitesi yüksek çocuk seçer.
Ve onları öğretmenlerine takdim eder.
Ve gerçekten de yılın sonunda,
bu beş özel çocuk en yüksek notları alır
ve en başarılı öğrenciler olur.
Ama ilginç olan şudur.
Aslında Profesör Rosenthal,
bu beş çocuğu rastgele seçmiştir.
Yani bu beş çocuğun diğerlerinden
ne zeka olarak ne yetenek olarak
ne de kapasite olarak herhangi
bir farkı ya da üstünlüğü yoktur.
Peki, fark nereden kaynaklanır?
Çocuklara üstün zekâlı,
özel çocuklar denmiştir.
Bu sözler sonrasında öğretmenlerinin
çocuklarla ilgili düşüncesi pozitif olur.
Bunun sonrasında öğretmenler çocuklara
daha fazla ilgi duyar, daha alakalı olur,
daha fazla onore eder, motive eder
ve öğrenmesi için çaba sarfeder.
Muhtemelen bir şeyi anlattığında çocuk
anlamayınca öğretmen şöyle demiş olabilir:
''Yani bu çocuk üstün zekâlı, anlamadıysa
herhalde bende bir problem var,
bir daha anlatayım.''
Peki böyle davranan öğretmenler
sonrasında öğrenciler ne düşünür?
''Ben özel bir çocuğum,
ben farklıyım, ben yapabilirim.''
Ve bunu düşünen çocuklar ne yapar?
Daha fazla çalışır.
Motivasyonları yüksek olduğu için azimle
derslere girer, büyük ilgi duyar derslere.
Ve gerçekten sonunda da daha başarılı
olurlar ve daha yüksek notlar alırlar.
Ve onların bu başarısı,
daha önceki öğretmenlerinin zihnindeki
o pozitif kanaati de pekiştirir.
İşte biz buna
''Pygmalion Etkisi'' diyoruz.
Yani kendini gerçekleştiren kehanet.
Bir de bunun tersi var, ''Golem Etkisi.''
Yani tam tersi, negatif sözcükler,
negatif hareketler ve negatif etkiler.
Şöyle özetleyebiliriz:
Hani bir insana 40 kere aptal
dersen aptal olur misali.
Üstad şöyle demiş:
''İyi ya da kötü yoktur, aslında
düşüncelerdir onları öyle yapan.''
Shakespeare'in bu güzel sözünü
daha da netleştirelim.
Hani biz deriz ya, biz aslında kişiye,
olaya, bir vakaya, sürece göre
bir iletişim kuruyoruz
ya da tepki veriyoruz.
Aslında değil.
Biz kişiye, olaya tepki vermiyoruz
ya da onunla iletişim kurmuyoruz.
Aslında ne yapıyoruz, biliyor musunuz?
Biz o kişiye, kavrama, sürece
hatta bir nesneye
verdiğimiz etikete göre
iletişim kuruyoruz,
bir davranışta bulunuyoruz
ya da tepki gösteriyoruz.
Örneğin şuradan tayyörlü bir kadın
geçse çoğumuz ne der?
İş dünyasının bir üyesi,
belki bir yönetici kadın.
Peki aynı kadını biz Afganistan'da
bir sokakta görsek ne olur?
Farklı, uzaylı hatta kimilerince
inançlara karşı çıkan katli vacip
bir nesneye bile dönüşebilir.
Kadın aynıdır hatta üstündeki
tayyör bile ama etiketler farklı.
Kavram.
Şimdi son dönemde liderlik kavramı,
herkesin konuştuğu, üzerine yorum yaptığı.
Liderlik kavramını nasıl
etiketlediğiniz, nasıl isimlerdiğiniz
sizin nasıl bir lider
olacağınızı tayin eder.
Eğer liderlik üzerine siz
''ben'' etiketini koyuyorsanız,
''hükümdar'' sözcüğünü koyuyorsanız,
yönetim anlayışınız nasıl olacaktır?
''Her şeyi ben bilirim,
her şeye ben karar veririm,
benim dediğim olur ve ben
hepsinin üstündeyim'' dersiniz
ve son derece otokratik
bir yönetim anlayışı benimsersiniz.
Kavram aynı kavramdır ama siz
onun üzerine ''biz'' etiketi koyarsanız,
''önderlik'' etiketi koyarsanız,
''ilham verici'' etiketi koyarsanız
bambaşka bir liderlik ortaya koyarsınız.
Daha katılımcı, daha demokratik
ve ''aklımın üstünde de
akıl vardır'' deyip
''akıllı insan başkalarının aklından da
yararlanan insandır'' deyip
birlikte bir liderlik
modeli inşa edersiniz.
Ya da nesneler.
Nesnelerle bile iletişim kuruyoruz.
Odaya girdiniz kırık bir ayna,
bazılarımız ne der?
Uğursuz.
İşte bir iletişim.
Eğer ona siz ''uğursuz''
etiketi koyarsanız
odadan çıkmak bile isteyebilirsiniz.
Ya da yoldan geçerken
önünüzden bir kara kedi geçer.
''Ayy'' dersiniz, ya siz kaçarsınız
ya kedi sizden kaçar.
Ama aslında kedinin bir suçu yoktur.
Siz sadece ona ''uğursuzluk''
etiketi koymuşsunuzdur.
Ve olaylar.
Damardan bir örnek vereceğim.
Ölüm, hepimizin sonu.
Aslında ölümden daha beteri,
yaşarken ölmek denilen şey
gerçekten sevdiğiniz birinin
öldüğünü görmektir.
Bu bazen anneniz, babanız
bazen eşiniz, sevgiliniz
bazen de evladınız, kardeşiniz olabilir.
Korkunç bir olaydır.
Eğer siz bu korkunç olaya
''son'' etiketi koyarsanız
düşüncelerinizde şunlar oluşur:
''O öldüyse ben de öldüm.
Yaşamak için hiçbir gayem kalmadı.
Benim için de bir son.'' dersiniz
ve davranışlarınız neye evrilir?
Hayattan kopma, depresyona girme
belki de intihara teşebbüs.
Olay aynı olaydır,
aynı korkunçlukta olaydır.
Ama siz o olaya ''son'' değil
''sınav'' etiketi koyarsanız ne olur?
O zaman düşüncelerinizde
şunları söylersiniz:
''Bu hayattaki belki de
en büyük imtihan.
Eğer ben bunu aşacak
dirayeti gösterebilirsem
sonrasında kaldığım yerden çok
daha güçlü adımlarla ilerleyebilirim.
Ve o sayede de hayatımın
son nefesine kadar
o sevdiğimin anılarını
benimle beraber yaşatabilirim.''
Gördüğünüz gibi olay aynı olaydır.
Ama nasıl sıfatlandırdığınız,
üzerine hangi etiketi koyduğunuz,
düşüncelerinizi, duygularınızı,
davranışlarınızı ve sonrasında da
yaşayacağınız hayatı belirler.
Bunu söylüyorum çünkü yaşadım.
Ve ben 2. etiketi koymayı tercih ettim
ve o sayede bugün burada karşınızdayım.
(Alkış)
Dolayısıyla etiketin üstüne
lütfen ne yazdığınıza dikkat edin.
Çünkü ne yazdıysanız yazgınız o olacaktır.
Peki etiketin üstüne her zaman
biz mi bir şeyler yazıyoruz?
Elbette hayır, bazen de birileri yazıyor.
Örneğin markete gittiniz, un alacaksınız,
un yazan paketi alıyorsunuz.
Ama sonrasında bir bakıyorsunuz ki
içindeki fare zehri.
Ne oldu? Tuhaf bir durum değil mi?
Olmayacak bir şey.
Ama gerçekte bunlar oluyor.
Yani un diye size fare zehri satıyorlar.
Bazen de fare zehrinin üzerine
un diye etiket koyuyorlar.
İşte bunun en çarpıcı örneğini
"1984" romanında George Orwell yazmıştır.
Öyle bir toplumdan bahseder ki
''Savaş, barıştır.''
''Özgürlük, köleliktir.''
''Cehalet de güçtür.''
Romanın ünlü mottosu
hatırlayacağınız gibi budur.
Yani cehaletin güç olarak etiketlendiği,
özgürlüğün kölelik olarak etiketlendiği
ve savaşın barış olarak
isimlendirildiği bir toplum.
Düşünün ne kadar tehlikeli.
Şimdi ben, günlük hayattan çoğumuzun
hemen hemen her gün maruz kaldığı
esprili birkaç örneği paylaşmak istiyorum.
Zam.
Zam var mı?
Elbette yok.
Zam yok, onun yerine ne var?
Güncelleme var.
Ekonomik küçülme var mı?
Yok, ne var?
Negatif büyüme var.
Zarar var mı?
Asla. Ne var?
Bütçe açığı var.
İşten çıkarma var mı? Hayır.
Yeniden yapılanıyoruz diyorlar ve
sizi rahatlıkla işten çıkartıyorlar.
Baskı var mı?
Güvenlik var.
Yasak var mı?
Hayır, düzenleme var.
İhmal var mı?
Hayır, kader o kader.
İhmal yok.
(Alkış)
Beyin yıkama var mı?
Hayır, haberler var.
Kibir var mı?
Hayır, özgüven var.
Ve malumunuz israf var mı?
Hayır, ne var?
İtibar var.
Ve --
(Alkış)
En önemlisi sadece
Gazi Mustafa Kemal yok,
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk var.
(Alkış)
Dolayısıyla sözcükler bir güçtür.
Lütfen ama lütfen sözcüklerinize dikkat
edin ve sözcüklerin gücünden yararlanın.
Sözcüklere hakim olan
dünyaya hakim olur demiştik.
Eğer siz sözcüklerinize hakim olup
sözcükleri güçlü bir şekilde
kullanmazsanız bilin ki birileri gelecek
ve o sözcükleri kullanarak
sizin zihin haritanızı işgal edecek.
O yüzden lütfen kimi zaman
karşınıza çıkan etiketlere dikkat edin.
Gerekirse o etiketleri sökün ve
arkasındaki gerçeği keşfedin.
Bu bir.
İkincisi, pozitif sözcüklere inanın.
Pozitif sözcüklerin gücüne inanın ve
göreceksiniz ki zihninizi temizleyecek,
yüreğinizi temizleyecek ve
hayatınızın kalitesini arttıracak.
Örneğin negatif sözcükleri olabildiğince
yaşamınızdan bertaraf edin, uzaklaştırın.
Siz üzeriniz kirlendiği zaman, lekelendiği
zaman tedirgin olmuyor musunuz?
Bir elbisenizin üzerindeki leke
bile sizi rahatsız edebiliyor.
Ama birileri ya da siz hatta kendinizi
kötü sözcükler söyleyerek
sürekli aslında zihninizi
lekeliyorsunuz ve kirletiyorsunuz.
O yüzden şunu yapabilirsiniz.
Mesela bir hafta boyunca bir kötü
söz söylediniz diyelim ki
onun karşılığında
beş pozitif sözcük söyleyin.
Hatta kötü sözleri
kendinize de söylemeyin.
''Ne kadar aptal bir adamım, ne kadar
beceriksiz bir kadınım'' demeyin.
Bunları söylemeyin.
Çünkü başarılı olacağım deseniz de
başarısız olacağım deseniz de
haklısınızdır aslında.
Onun için sözcüklerin gücüne inanın
ve bunları uygulayın.
Madem bu kadar güçlü sözcüklerden
ve güzel sözcüklerden bahsettik.
Tılsımlı, sihirli sözcüklerle
bitirelim istiyorum.
Hakikaten dünyanın neresinde
olursanız olun bunlar tılsımlı sözcükler.
''Günaydın'' muhteşem sihirli bir sözcük.
''Merhaba.''
''Teşekkür ederim.''
''Rica ederim.''
''Lütfen.''
''Özür dilerim.''
Zor ama çok sihirli bir sözcük.
''Başarılar.''
Başarıları lütfen söyleyin.
Tebrik edin, kutlayın.
''Tebrikler.''
''Sana güveniyorum.''
Ve en sihirli sözcük, sizden bekliyorum.
''Seni seviyorum.''
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)
Sözcüklerinizi değiştirin,
dünyanız değişsin.
(Alkış)